everything the
whole story
with more details
and for All my life I feel like it Who I
am And I didn't feel like I was a woman
[Music]
my Friends don't know
I am is just I want to see Who a really
am
[Music] I'm
still who I am, it's just that I want you to
see who I really am
[Music] You
left me speechless,
you have words,
yes,
it's not like a little bit worrying because I
have very little knowledge about
that topic.
Yes, and they make us very anxious
Well  The truth is, I was
speechless, but at the same time
I admire the way people are honest,
and we didn't know the
previous person, we know this Gabriel at
this moment
and we met you first as a great
friend. True,
[Music] I have
had  bad experiences when
people just took away all the love
for me the feeling is from
inside but not what is outside right
thank you
[Music]